so yesterday david carr listed on an
item at nfl.com the 10 quarterbacks to
target via free agency trader the draft
this year and he mentions at number two
russell wilson and he mentions
the four teams for which russell wilson
would play via trade from the seahawks
the bears saints cowboys and the raiders
the raiders current starting quarterback
david carr's younger brother derek carr
if i'm one of those four teams
i.e the raiders i'm picking up the phone
yesterday
he russell wilson is everything you want
a quarterback with endless talent arm
strength poison intelligence plus he has
the kind of ice in his veins that gives
his team a chance to win in late games
no matter how great the deficit i was
stunned by that i wrote the article i
sent it around to you and pete and matt
yesterday chris and i couldn't believe
it and you had a great theory that
that hey maybe derek gave the nod to
this because he's sick of the
speculation right so yeah so but wait oh
wait oh no no no that wasn't the case
the the the phrase
one of those four teams
was changed to if i'm a quarterback
needy team i'm picking up the phone
yesterday and let me tell you this first
of all
saying if i'm a quarterback needy team
makes no sense in context because it's
one paragraph after the paragraph where
he talks about russell wilson limiting
the universe of teams to four
so if you're any of those other teams
other than the four that have been
identified you're wasting your time
calling up so uh this was funny to me
and and the way it was changed
no evidence that it was changed no
update to the time stamp no editor's
note no anything it was just oh crap
i can't believe i did that
let's make the change and let's never
mention it again and let's hope no one
notices oops i i i mean originally i was
shocked when you sent along the the you
know the article and all those things i
thought well
there's no way
he writes this unless he talked to his
brother
and his brother was like hey
you had the hell with this i'm sick of
dealing with this every year fine go
ahead write it tell them to trade for me
you know that's what i texted you right
i mean that's what that's what it
appeared to me
um but obviously you know after the
amendment change there uh there there
must have been some sort of phone call
or text message like yo dude what the
hell i'm your brother
and
uh my wife is pissed off because we
don't want to move we just moved into
this house what are you doing like so
i'm sure that was a very awkward awkward
exchange certainly and hey listen we
know russell wilson's awesome there's no
doubt about that uh and is he better
than derek uh derek carr yes he is
um but i i
man the raiders they're one of those
teams where hey i look at john gruden
and go yeah i think he'd love to have a
guy like russell wilson but like we
talked about yesterday you know he's got
his robot wired finally in a derek carr
and
as we talked about last week when we hit
the afc west teams
i mean
the raiders got they need they got they
got holes i mean their defense is stinky
they need players and if they were going
to trade derek carr
for for russell wilson they were odd
they're obviously going to have to give
up assets and picks and things like that
to get him there's going to be something
that goes along with that
and that's where i just don't think it
makes sense at least from that
standpoint
peter king and i were kicking it around
last week he thought that that maybe
derek carr
jonathan abram
and hunter renfro
plus a pick or two could get it done
that i mean that's a possibility i mean
that is uh but yeah i mean you know i
don't think the the seahawks i don't
think need safety help right now but it
would probably take something like that
i think that's yeah maybe maybe one of
the young corners they have something
like that maybe that would have to be
thrown into there that would make a
little more sense to me than the than
the safeties but yeah probably something
similar to that to get get the job done
and i don't know if the raiders would be
willing to do that right now or not uh
you know they abram of course is a first
round pick and yeah he's been a little
wild and crazy but he does have talent
and he does have attitude and that's
that's hard to replace so so i just
don't see it happening i don't know i
don't and i'm just again i don't know
where this russell wilson thing's gonna
go
uh and it'll be interesting but that was
very odd yesterday family on family
crime
in the nfl
and and your take i thought was
compelling the idea that maybe derek
carr has had enough of it because it's
out there that russell wilson wants to
play for the raiders and the raiders
haven't come out and said
no no derek carr is our guy and what
have we heard from mike mayok the gm of
the team for the last couple of years
every time he talks about quarterbacks
he says we're looking constantly for a
potential upgrade remember they kicked
tires on kyler murray and dwayne haskins
yeah in 2019. why because we're
constantly looking for upgrades at all
positions including quarterbacks so at a
certain point you do get sick if you're
derek carr my my wild guess as to what
happened here is
that david carr just kind of provided
the list to someone else
at nfl.com and that someone else wrote
it up and he read it and he didn't
notice it and he said okay
and then he got the wtf text from his
brother after we posted the thing
yesterday yeah and okay think about this
in 2018 the last time that david carr
listed his top 10 nfl quarterbacks he
listed his brother higher than russell
wilson which is mind-blowing in and of
itself uh yeah yes it is uh
there's no doubt i mean listen car
derek cars had some moments we know that
you know he was really damn good that
year he broke his you know leg or ankle
before they went to the playoffs man was
he clutch he had like ice water in his
veins that year so i can understand it
being closer that year certainly but
ever since that point i mean russell
wilson's that wasn't the year though
that was a year that was the year after
you're right 18. yeah 2017 was the year
that he was just good enough to get jack
del rio fired for john gruden yeah all
right so yeah they had no they
that shouldn't have been that close
there and then of course russell wilson
the last few years has gone into super
stardom i mean russell wilson is a rare
talent in the fact that
he is as clutch as they come he's one of
those guys mike that really like when he
doesn't happen at the end of the
football game and he doesn't make the
big throw you're like what how i can't
believe it he always does i mean he's
he's as clutch as they come in the nfl
in those type of moments and of course
he can carry a team in certain moments
too and make plays that are just off the
charts good so that's the aspect he
brings to the game you know derek carr
is really good but he does need
system help you know and i don't mean to
say that you know in a derogatory way
i'm just saying listen there's only a
few guys in the world that are like a
russell wilson that can do what he can
do
derek carr is awesome when you give him
an awesome i mean offense he can make
really good decisions he's a high level
thrower he's very accurate
and he does have a lot of value as an
nfl starting quarterback but yeah at
this point i think russell wilson's a
little bit in the different stratosphere
the oddsmaker's unmoved by the recent
talk about russell wilson leaving the
agent identifying the four teams for
which russell wilson would play
points bet has seattle at minus 12 50 as
the next destination the next place that
russell wilson will take a snap so that
means he's going nowhere according to
the odds but beyond that the favorite
would be the las vegas raiders at plus
450 i'm surprised dallas is where they
are i think dallas is the least likely
of the four teams to go after russell
wilson for a very very simple reason
first of all there's no way you can
include
jack prescott really there's
yeah you're still blocked by him right
i was i've always been i don't know what
i did to be blocked that's what bothers
me about it more than anything else
when you get blocked by someone and you
have no idea what you did
to trigger it now there have been times
in the past where it's like i know this
guy's going to block me based on this
tweet but i hadn't i i have i'm clueless
as to what i ever said or did to get
derrick carr to block
i'm sure you did something i mean well
this is stirring up family drama that's
good this is your first time down down
that lane but i i don't think uh you
know it may not be the first time yeah
it might not be the first time the first
time they've given me something it's the
first time they've given me something
that's made it so easy okay so i i'm
sure if we went through your timeline
there's funny plenty of things that
justified him blocking you i'm sure i'm
sure of that what was i saying earlier
oh i was saying about the cowboys i just
of all the teams that russell wilson's
named i just it makes no sense it makes
no sense for the cowboys to do it but
that probably means they'll be the ones
who do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports